I asked him about his like first
performance ever what do you remember
about yours oh um so I started off doing
singing competitions as you know and the
last time you know we talked about it it
was fun and then when I first did my
like first show at the Norva in Virginia
Beach where I'm from uh that was a whole
different ball game and I still did a
cover at the time yeah I was probably 10
or 11 and I sang I Want To Dance With
Somebody by Whitney Houston I loved it
that was your song oh yep there yeah
yeah
I love that though that's such a that's
such a big fun song everybody loves that
song yes it was my favorite I mean who
didn't love Whitney who doesn't love
Whitney yeah absolutely and if you don't
you're dumb
um so you have no ears um oh no yeah I
want to talk to you if you don't love me
yeah I was like what how do you not like
her voice um I heard that when you were
out doing shows that young though your
grandma used to pet sit for you and
maybe she wasn't the best at it this is
a funny story actually a lot of stories
every time my family and I would go on
vacation if it was like five days or
seven days I would leave my I had birds
with her my cockatiels okay and
every time I came back the birds would
be gone and the cage would be open and
my grandma would be like I just let them
out for some air and I'm like I'm like
but for the third time you let them out
for some air so every time I got back
from vacation I would keep getting new
birds and I think I don't think she
liked birds or she just didn't like them
cage she was like they want to go out
she was like they want to go I just
maybe that's what it is but she really
was just like I let them breathe some
good fresh air and they didn't come back
I think the most amazing part is you
kept allowing her to watch them I know I
know I was so young you know I stopped
getting him after I was like obviously
she's not gonna do it this time oh and
get them again I love that it's not like
a normal pet that most people pick I
love that you pick Birds that's so what
your Songbird that makes sense um but
anything ever gone horribly wrong on
stage when you were just like so many
things me too so many things almost
every time there's something because you
think it's gonna go like the way you
planned but no it doesn't and I usually
have something like a shoe probably like
is kind of like I have to wear like
multiple socks under my boots in my
boots so like they're really tight yeah
because I feel like if they're a little
loose I like I'm gonna fall so I tripped
once I one other time my bra popped off
and like thank God thank God I had like
this sparkly top over the sheer top but
it was sheer so when it popped off I was
like whoa I'm like okay hello everybody
so I'm just gonna stay like this and No
One's Gonna Know remind me not to buy
that bra that specific brand you know I
thought it was cute but it's different
when you have kids it's not cute
um so what's your what's its different I
give life to kids um so what's what's
your moment do you ever have a moment on
stage where you're like okay that was
not planned
well I remember doing doing a show Once
uh it was part of a festival in Rio I
think it was a hot was it Hollywood Rock
or Rock In Rio or something like that
okay and I remember running onto the
stage and they had these bright floor
lights and I tripped like literally
before I sang a single though I tripped
over the stage fell over the light fell
flat in my face cut up all my uh leg and
then had to kind of finish the show I
had to actually had to sing for the next
hour or so but do you get up and address
it or do you not
um well back then I can't what did I do
I just I was a bit shaken but I just
kind of continued and now I probably I'd
take a moment and make fun of myself and
that's 100 me yeah so I'd probably I
can't not talk about it because it's
funny like falling it is funny like it's
like didn't play on that but just right
on my face in front of thousands of
people it's totally happened to me too
except the microphone was like oh
[Music]
yeah I was like all right not cool
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]